when you have six weekends I don't
understand you sir dude
I do have small weak hands and I'm so
glad you notice that James Corden took a
picture with Sean Spicer and everyone
was so outraged about it that this
absolute pardon my language spoiler
alert she apologized watch some people
have been disappointed by this photo in
truth I'm disappointed by it as well I
am a bear I've been reading a lot of
harsh comments on Twitter today and I
hear you loud and clear truly I do so
much so I'm really starting to regret
that carpool karaoke that we've taped
with Steve Bannon feels like feels like
a mistake today
now with Courtney doesn't really bother
me because he's not even funny
accidentally but like me it you know I
just and by the way I would have sworn
he was gonna if I don't get a wife I'm
like ah poor broad but it always makes
me really sad when I see comedians
apologize you know why because I know
exactly what's going it doesn't get
better for you
it's not like it's not like a
relationship you know relationship where
it's it's not a contract it's a covenant
my wife and I we were talking about this
like my wife can if she were to throw my
clothes out in the lawn I you know I I
still love her but I don't like that she
did that right there's no covenant with
comedians and the media and they think
there is like hey if I apologize are we
gonna work no the goal is to call now as
they've achieved a battle on the way to
winning this war Dave Chappelle I was
when he apologized for telling viewers
to give Trump a chance for telling yours
to give Trump a chance it's not like he
went up and said it's a hail hit he said
you know give the man a chance Amy
Schumer apologize I'm not an Amy Schumer
favor I don't think she'd apologize for
racist rape jokes you made her out
Hispanic she apologized Tracy Morgan
apologized for the anti-gay comments
that he made at a Nashville show was so
disappointing when Daniel Tosh
apologized for the rape joke and a lot
of this by the way comes from pressure
from from management and the reason it's
so foolish is because the left this is
important to note and again politics you
know culture is upstream from politics
the left will not stop at if you see
something really offensive like okay
I'll give
say Daniel Tosh's rape joke you find it
really offensive it doesn't matter but
I'll give you that for the sake of
argument right okay you say [ __ ] but
that's not what they want
just like with daca it's not that they
want kids to stay they don't want us to
deport people who've actually committed
crimes so they're not looking for what
you think their goal is case in point
they want to tell you what kind of
comedy you can do period Daily Beast's
writer this article just went up
criticized Jerry Seinfeld's latest
special let me read this Jerry Seinfeld
stand-up comedy is still about nothing
but should it stand for something no he
was Jerry Seinfeld leads actually use
the term has little points in the
article ah thank you for telling one of
the most prolific comedic writers of our
generation how to do his job Daily Beast
columnist Jerry Seinfeld didn't take a
picture with Sean Spicer which
apparently is is an actionable offense
now didn't even do that he's just done
what Jerry Seinfeld has always done his
entire life and as well yeah but
shouldn't you maybe not do that was that
maybe yeah like I get how you're talking
about
peanuts on the airline but what about
police brutality they get mad at you for
things that you do and then they get mad
at you for things that you don't do like
Jimmy Fallon it actually apologized in
an interview for not being mean enough
to Donald Trump he said I didn't mean to
humanize him oh so you're apologizing
for not treating a president Eenie
humanely this is what the left wants
from you Jimmy Fallon it wasn't like hey
Jimmy Fallon you made a rape joke so you
should apologize yeah no it was Jimmy
Fallon you treated Donald Trump as you
treat every guest don't you think you
should have been mean to the guy and he
actually he felt bad about it he
polished this is the point if they're
going to try and tell Jerry Seinfeld how
he should write jokes and should quote
unquote read The Daily Beast article
maybe get woke they're going after Jimmy
Fallon who is the most inconsequential
pandering milquetoast spineless ass
kisser no matter who ever is on his show
[Music]
hey Balu show
I'm Jimmy Fallon which is which is good
right is that good haha it's great we
have an awesome show tonight it's we
have one of the best cast ever he's like
he's the best I was reading his book in
my bubble bath
it's Justin Timberlake and I realized I
couldn't read the book because it's in
Russian which is great right listen
gentlemen give it up just stop so gray
who was the last one to clip I don't
understand why you have so many nice
things when you have such weak hands I
don't understand you sir dude I do have
small weak hands and I'm so glad you
notice that how great is that you just
told me back in the masculine world it's
so great so tell me about this thing
communism sounds the Russian winter a
man is only what he can endure
every man can have pet dog but which of
you man can eat that dog
[Applause]
and that's great because like dodds food
I mean you must love hot dogs right
didn't rush you read them in America
that you have has turned your brain to
mush it is turn your men into women like
you're freaked
falen your neighbors will look away when
we take you they always look away
[Applause]
oh that's so great I mean how's the best
ladies and gentlemen please give it up
for Joseph stout and nobody stop
clapping cause he like he kills that guy
we're gonna get home you'll find go to
wife and children I'm dead
we come back me and Henry Stiles are
gonna be whacking each other off on
ferris wheel and then we play beer pong
with kim jeong-hoon
[Music]
hey did you enjoy this video here's the
thing you wrote you're here this is the
end of it so we don't care cuz you
already watched it but if you really
didn't like it and you want to justify
it leave a comment below telling us why
you didn't like the video and if you
liked us let us know and subscribe to
the channel because that lets the
overlords at YouTube know that you know
what you're alright